many Republicans have condemned the
attack on Paul Pelosi but some others
have made light of it including Kerry
Lake who is in a tight race for governor
in Arizona she brought the assault up
when replying to a question about safety
in schools listen
protect our kids at school
they act like it is Nancy Pelosi well
she's got protection when she's in DC
apparently her house doesn't have a lot
of protection but
so laughter from the crowd that also
really gets you now it's bringing Robert
Costa who's in Pennsylvania following
the campaign there uh Bob good morning I
want to talk about Pennsylvania but
first a clip we just heard from Kerry
Lake we've got Mike Pence we've got Ben
sass other Republicans condemning the
attack she's taking a different route
what do those comments say about our
current political climate
good morning she is taking a different
route think back to 2010 that year of a
republican wave the Tea Party Movement
Republicans that year ran on a fire
Pelosi campaign she was then a Target
politically of scorn in ridicule her
Republican critics cast her as a San
Francisco elitist and really for more
than a decade now that approach to
Pelosi has continued and even at this
traumatic moment for her and her family
the laughter at that event is not that
surprising and the fact that it's not
that surprising is revealing of our
deeply partisan deeply divided political
moment which continues across the
country ahead of the midterms yeah it
sure does and speaking of the midterms
Bob you're in Pennsylvania we are one
week away from election day it's a
senate race there between a republican
Dr Mehmet Oz and Democrat John fetterman
fetterman had been leading in polls up
until right about now it's very very
close couldn't be closer what's
happening there
it's now a battle for Suburban voters Dr
mehmadaz will be here in Bucks County
Pennsylvania later today a vote-rich
area outside of Philadelphia a swing
place where many voters live both
parties are targeting you see now that
in the final days Oz is focusing on
crime which is an issue in nearby
Philadelphia trying to win over those
Suburban voters his top Ally former
president Donald Trump will be in
Pennsylvania later this week Democrats
want to remind Suburban Philadelphia
voters about that Oz Trump connection
Democratic Lieutenant Governor John
fetterman is campaigning across the
state months after suffering a stroke
trying to show voters he's vigorous he's
fine he's recovering he's focusing on
abortion rights and democracy in these
closing days Tony
Bob Costa for us on the overall
political climate and the picture there
in Pennsylvania Bob thank you very much